delays cancelled flights and being stuck
in the middle seat may no longer be
people's biggest air travel concerns a
new possibility awaits
double-decker-style airplane seats for
coach but no this is not really
double-decker these are
on the same level of the plane but if
you're on the lower level your face
would be directly up against somebody's
rear end they figure i guess you can't
smell the farts well enough on planes
already so they want to fix that problem
and now you'll be able to smell you know
the guy in front of you who's eating the
burrito bowl you can smell his his lunch
on on both ends i suppose i'll never get
over the fact that airplanes have
somehow declined in quality over the
past 50 years our faces directly in the
firing line of another passenger's butt
with three inches of leg room
chained to the seats
forced to flap our arms out the window
to keep the plane in the sky
that's what it's like in coach anyway
which is why i just fly first class to
avoid all of that help me i'm poor